when the reunion does happen believe you
me I will be walking in there okay with
guns blazing trust their wigs down
telling me all right miss Leakes thanks
for joining us we're calling these our
quarantine Diaries or quarantine
confessionals while we're all trapped
inside
how is a life at home for you right now
everything is great at home for me but
you know I actually I've gotten to know
my house a whole lot better because I
kind of treat my house like a hotel you
know I'm in an amount because I travel
two or three times a week so I'm never
really here so now I know what my house
needs and what it doesn't need now so
it's okay I get dressed up to walk down
to the kitchen you still look quite glam
for staying home or how is your beauty
routine changed in all this um I did
this this was very hard for me to do I'm
sure I look a hot mess
you know I tried to flatten my hair and
I tried to put a little makeup line but
I'm not a good makeup girl I I love
makeup so I have someone to do it for me
so I actually called to him this morning
and asked him and he'd been around
anybody he said no and I asked him was
he okay with entering the basement door
and putting on you know masks and gloves
and booties and everything and he said
I'm so I'm so fat I'm so fine with it
because I want to get out of the house
too but I thought about it went on
social media and I kept looking around I
was I call to myself don't calm yeah I
do it myself I really want him to come
but I was like just don't come I read
all of this stuff about people in New
York I just like forget it
what are you watching what are you
binging to take your mind off of all
this so the only thing that I've watched
since we've been in has been reality
show and seeing in which I really want
them to block seeing in on my teeth I
can't even take it anymore it's too much
what reality shows other than Housewives
what reality shows do you watch i watch
everything that's on here the Love & Hip
Hop just anything that's on yeah I love
this is not a reality show it's nap
snap oh the stuff and I loved watching
that I was like one day I was in here
watch me and it was just going on and on
and on and on just one show after the
next so yeah don't let Greg see you
watching too many marathons he might
think I was just hooked on it
it was it was so crazy I was like oh my
gosh these people are crazy
we're also asking everybody because it
feels like we're all snacking way more
as we're trapped inside
what are we snacking on are you kidding
me I am big as a house over here I eat
everything seriously I went onto YouTube
and I and I put in the search engine I'm
looking for someone to help me with arms
like light weights and arms and I'm
gonna follow somebody on there because I
need to work out I listen my hips have
gotten wider I'm a white truck up in
here girl
so I love salt so I've eaten all the
potato chips all the cookies like oh my
goodness I even we have a bar in our
house but I don't like to go down to the
bar and fix a drink so when we went to
grocery shop
I said get those frozen drinks that's in
the freezer area that's already like NYX
I've been eating them and drinking them
cuz I love the ice in it oh my god
they're looking at 50 calories peach I
was having like four a day
like I eat oh my god I have some Girl
Scout cookies oh my you can't eat just
one sleeve yep eats a whole you just
can't use one of these at home please oh
yeah oh my god we got to keep ourselves
entertained in some way and it seems
like food is a big source of
entertainment right now you don't get
out of this house is gonna eat up all my
snacks and you and kandi are uh kept us
entertained with a little social media
back and forth in all this yeah which I
thought was really stupid
yeah what that was about I thought that
she was reaching it's really not that
serious to me I don't have an issue with
her which is why I didn't entertain it
anymore I was like okay so this once
again is proving everything that I say
about the show if I say one little thing
is bigger than life but it's okay
for them to say anything they want to
say and I said no one can say that I
haven't sat here this season and let
these girls Austin they're interviewing
say whatever they wanted to say they
rolled their eyes they said everything
now I define myself once and then it's a
whole big issue well we're gonna have a
lot of issues because I'm gonna clean
myself is you better come ready because
I'm going to defend myself yeah yeah the
reunion whatever you guys get to film
that I feel like you're gonna come in
and you're gonna lay it down this time
last year you kind of sat back you were
like yeah yeah so going on last year and
is it a lot of things that have been
unfair throughout this entire season the
rules don't apply to everyone in my
opinion the rules are very one-sided and
once again I feel like if I'm doing
something there's a much brighter light
shined on it and they do much worse of
things to each other in the fight okay
I'm sorry
okay sorry sorry but with me it has to
be bigger than life so when the reunion
does happen believe you me I will be
walking in there okay with guns blazing
trust they are their wigs down Bellamy
what's the number one thing you want to
address there that you want to like
clear up or get them hold them
accountable for one moment I don't think
I I've said and I think I said on social
media it's the fact that they all tried
to join together to form and some sort
of Alliance to push me out now how do
you push me out this show that I am the
foundation of us that doesn't even make
sense to me you can't push me out of my
own show like it when I get ready to
leave this show it's gonna be on my own
will like it's not even how they
wouldn't even hear when this show
started
they won't even hear what we were
pitching the show like how dare you kind
of join forces and try to say let's not
being with her girl you wouldn't even be
on this show if it wasn't for her right
well you've proven you can also take
time away from the show and come back
instead I would you know what even if I
left I really love to see what they
would do I can tell you right now they
would turn on each other like it's
nothing they would turn it was what else
are they gonna do and I can see you know
I read a lot of stuff you know I
obviously I've been at home okay
somewhere they said like some of the OGS
are being pushed out there looking for
much younger women I said well you must
be looking on the rock cause I can see
it by any of these girls and they can't
hold a mesh to me when it comes down to
age okay cuz a lot of them have a lot of
jarred bags under their eyes to be so
young
what this season has really a lot of the
drama and a lot of conversation has been
around you for these things you've said
of them coming at you no matter what
small thing big thing it's always at you
and a lot of the season has been you and
Kenya and I know it's not over yet
because I know at Kandi's baby shower
some more goes down do you gonna do that
with me man I wanna be what you want
Kenya wants to continue to argue with me
obviously there's nothing there the
whole world can see that there's nothing
there it's not that serious
I mean we have footage after footage at
the footage of her saying nasty things
to people from the day she ever walked
through the doors of the Real Housewives
of Atlanta and she's even said things
about me I didn't hold them against her
because we're on a show right but she
wanted to hold this against me and roll
with it to the end because I am NeNe
Leakes and when you connect your name
with NeNe Leakes name people pay
attention so and these girls know that
so that's why they do what they do and
that's why I can't he did what she did
and that's like Kenya did what she did
that's why any of them do what they do
because they feel like with Nene name
it's a rocket that means if I am that
girl you know that right oh yeah well I
loved I think you said it maybe in one
of your lives that it's Kenya's trying
to be
Kim Zolciak like she's not on that level
with you he'll responded did you see
that I did and she said never gonna
happen I really do feel like she's
trying to take that see
Kim Zolciak but the problem with that is
Kenya is that Kim and I had a real
friendship we actually lived in the same
neighborhood we had a real friendship so
there were real feelings there with you
it's like eating cardboard it's dry no
thank you
is there any hope that you two can get
to a place where it's no longer a back
and forth
I don't think friendships ever on the
table but like just coexist I'm that way
I'm that way now I when I left Greece I
was fine I have no problem with I didn't
have a problem coming to Greece and I
don't have a problem talking to her
because I know that it was all made up
right so I was like girl cut it out like
it's time to cut it out in there because
there's no real issue here cut it out
but for her to not ever want to cut it
out and the things that I've heard her
say was that they use my daughter my
husband and my mother those are the
three things you don't use against me
girl have you forgotten the footage that
we have of you talking about everybody's
husband and marriage from kim feel's
- Porsha - Phaedra you know - everyone
liked it - it doesn't make sense how
dare you have the rules apply to
everyone but yourself so safe to say
that blow up we're gonna see at the
party is her Fanning the flame again but
see and you see how provoking and
everything I can't wait for you to see
it provokes she gets up out of her seat
walks around and stand beside me like
girl you have to stop that because
somebody's going to beat you down like
you can't just do that to people in
heated moments and think that it's okay
it's Cheney to be held accountable for
doing things like that doesn't make
sense you know what the show I I love to
see a real battery there's some real
issue there it's okay but when the issue
is not that real it's like I don't know
I guess they call it making good TV I
don't know I call it making it
stupidness well yeah
hey I'm such a sweetheart you would just
love me you would just love me and me
only well can't wait see what goes down
at the reunion
well I can't either but I can tell you
it's probably gonna be a pretty good
reunion because from what I've seen
already on social media it seems like
they are already trying to get each
other already some of the things I've
read and seen I'm like okay so I mean
all of you guys started out together now
you turning on each other
interesting yeah it's gonna be
especially with this extended amount of
time between filming now this extra who
knows how long I'm sure some more things
will pop up and feelings will come to
the surface and all that yeah you know I
hope it's not super super long because I
worry that I worry that you know time
heals right yeah so I worry that the
same energy won't be buried you know
what I'm saying yeah only because time
heals and people get over stuff and so
that's one of my fears yeah it could go
one way or the other
um you said you've been open that you
kind of reevaluate after every season if
you're gonna come back if you want to
come back if it's the right place for
you so I'm imagine you're still kind of
in that mindset because the seasons
technically not wrapped up yet still
reunion two films do all that to go
through but if you could play casting
director on the show
what's the mix of girls you would like
to actually see on the cast
if you could pick everybody who's around
from seasons past present future oh well
we have a great cast right now except
for one person I think I think only one
person on this cast then seemed to have
carried any weight this season and I
think that's very obvious who that
person is and I don't think that they
actually fit in the cast that well so
can you name names that well you know
there's this one they're probably one of
the newest people on the cast right now
maybe maybe miss Eva Marcille I don't
feel like Eva brings that much you know
it's really I'm just being honest it's
really when you look at a show like
everybody's out of the whole cast is
away and you don't miss the person at
all it's sort of like we didn't even
know you were here
you know and all season doing a lot of
things from face
time that's been the last couple of
seasons so I don't really see I don't I
don't know I don't know so if I if I had
to change I will change her and I bring
back someone from the pasture said yeah
Breaking Bad someone from the past I
would rain came back but I know Kim
doesn't want to come back would you say
are low into a full-time role there yeah
maybe slap Milo in there because I don't
really know anybody from the past that's
really interesting because when they
left because they pretty much wasn't
that interesting that's why they been
gone but Kim is pretty interesting so
she's a good one to bring back if
Phaedra hadn't burned the house down she
just burned the house cotton when she
was leaving so she can I yeah that's
kind of bad but I still would like to
see her come on like as a friend of the
show play around for a couple of
episodes because I still think there's
unfinished business there I think it is
unfair for the rest of the cast to face
people who they have issues with and
then she doesn't get to face who she has
an issue here so the one time that she
had a real issue with somebody all of a
sudden they have to be off the show so I
don't think that part is and I think
it's okay for me to speak my opinion
about that kandi and I will continue to
do that it would be nice to get a little
check in on her too because it's been a
couple years now her life is different
now yeah yeah it was great to see you
and Cynthia get to a place where you can
at least be friendly again because
people love that relationship love that
friendship
did you see the tick tock her daughter
did recreating the reunion fight from
last year between you and Eva well I
actually didn't like something that you
say it myself oh is that why we got the
energy
no what energy is it because your energy
is real like raw today well raw
what do you mean it's very aggressive
aggressive what do you mean like he was
hitting Thank You diva
I assume you're upset about something no
I said about anything why wouldn't you
have banter with me that's my point that
it's like you're
your fillings but beyond Andy what was
the question she said that she didn't
like it that you said that is all about
people like a couple people reached out
to me asking me you know did I see and
it's not that serious me if it was a
argument with Eva it couldn't have been
to you we're really learning how you
feel about Eva you know I don't have any
harsh feelings towards her
it appears that she has harsh feelings
towards me
it proved it all season long with her
sitting in the car with Cynthia riding
rolling her eyes having all these things
to say as if I really do something to
her maybe I stole her baby and I didn't
know you know who knows who knows I
could anything happens with me you know
everything is so elevated so yeah
federal crime the person who actually
brought information on it which is
Marvel so she walks around being mad at
me but I'm the girl who she's been
friends with for 10 years and I'm like a
sister right I would imagine this whole
thing to change subjects here for a
second has also impacted the Comedy Tour
right yes yes we were headed to Vegas so
I didn't I know it's hard to plan life
right now but safe to say ladies I doubt
we'll pick up when we get out of this
yeah we are right now we're looking at
we already had a schedule anyway and I
scheduled for October is Atlanta Georgia
so we're keeping October on the book so
right now we're kind of thinking that we
won't be able to get back out on the
road until like October because Live
Nation and a ger those big companies
they don't really know if they're
putting concerts to shows back up or not
so I'll wait and see before I let you go
anything else you want to say about the
season about what's coming up or things
you want fans to know oh my gosh do you
think I want to say well what I have to
say to the fans out there is to please
stay safe and stay home wash your hands
and do all those take all those
precautions if you read as much as I do
it is very serious I'm totally freaked
out so I you know I will hope you guys
will be safe so that you can see the
reunion
in advance six
[Music]